dangerous extremist Republican Governor
Ron DeSantis has signed a bill into law
that would allow trans kids to be taken
from their families if they are
undergoing certain types and in certain
situations of gender affirming care this
is effectively a law that lets the state
kidnap children kidnap children medical
facilities have to give the State
Department of Health a signed
attestation that they did not Prov
provide gender affirming care to any
patients under age 18 or make any such
referrals their medical license renewal
is also contingent upon sending in this
attestation so this is dangerous for the
kids this is dangerous for the medical
providers and this is exactly the type
of right-wing hellscape that the entire
country might become
if Ron DeSantis somehow managed to
become president of the United States